>> Laura: MEMBERS FROM
GENERATION E BELIEVE HE OR SHE
SHOULD GET INTO THE BEST
COLLEGES, EVEN IF HE OR SHE DOES
NOT HAVE THE BEST GRADES.
OR THE BEST SCORES.
THEY DEVELOP THEIR REVIEW OF
THERE IS SELF-IMPORTANCE BECAUSE
MOMMY AND DADDY RAISED THEM
BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE SPECIAL.
WHAT'S THE END RESULT HERE?
MANY OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE, IT'S
NOT JUST THE WEALTHY KIDS, THEY
GROW UP TO BE DEMANDING,
ENTITLED ADULTS.
MY NEXT GUEST HAS BECOME A
SENSATION, TOURING COLLEGES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND OFFERING
THE MESSAGE THAT I STRESSED INTO
NICE ANGLE.
JOINING ME NOW, BEN SHAPIRO,
EDITOR IN CHIEF OF
TheDailyWire.com.
I WANT TO BEGIN WITH WHAT WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT EARLIER.
IT DOVETAILS INTO EVERYTHING YOU
WRITE IN YOUR BOOK, THE EMERGING
POLITICS OF GRIEVANCE AND
ENTITLEMENT, GENERATION E.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON HOW TO BEST
THWART THIS, COME BACK THIS,
CURE THIS?
>> I THINK THE BEST WAY TO
COMBAT A LOT OF THIS STUFF IS TO
FOCUS ON ACHIEVEMENT AND FREEDOM
AND RESPONSIBILITY.
THE FACT HIS FREEDOM COMES ALONG
WITH THE DUTY TO ACHIEVE.
YOU ARE NOT OWED ANYTHING IN
THIS WORLD, WHY SHOULD YOU
PERCEIVE YOURSELF TO BE OWED A
COLLEGE LOCK LOOKS LIKE WHY
SHOULD YOUR PARENTS GIVE YOU
EVERYTHING?
THAT MENTALITY IS FOREIGN TO A
LOT OF THE BASIS OF WESTERN
CIVILIZATION AND THE BASIS FOR
AMERICA, THIS IDEA THAT WE WERE
SUPPOSED TO GO FORTH AND
CONQUER, THAT WE WERE SUPPOSED
TO GO IN THE WILDERNESS AND
BUILD SOMETHING OUT THERE.
THAT HAS BEEN ABANDONED IN FAVOR
OF THIS GRIEVANCE CULTURE AS YOU
SEE THAT SAYS THE WORLD OWED
SOMETHING, IF WE DON'T GET IT
IT'S BECAUSE THE SYSTEM HAS
FAILED US.
>> Laura: EVEN THE SHIRT THAT
THE YOUNG WOMAN WAS WEARING, THE
T-SHIRT WHEN SHE WAS CONFRONTING
CHELSEA CLINTON -- OF ALL
PEOPLE, CHELSEA CLINTON?
ISN'T THAT KIND OF, I'M
SIMPLISTIC OF THE PHRASE JUMP
THE SHARK, BUT ISN'T THAT
TELLING YOU A LOT OF HOW JUST
PATHETIC THIS WHOLE ENTITLEMENT
MOVEMENT HAS GONE, WHEN CHELSEA
CHRISTMAN
CLINTON IS TARGETED?
>> WHEN CHELSEA CLINTON IS TOO
RADICAL FOR YOU BECAUSE SHE'S
TOO FAR THE RIGHT, I DON'T THINK
HE JUMPED THE SHARK, YOU JUMP
THE ENTIRE AQUARIUM.
IT'S STOMACH SUBJECTIVE FEELING
HAS TAKEN
THE PLACE OF OBJECTIVE FACT.
SHE WAS SPEAKING ANTI-SEMITISM,
CHELSEA CLINTON CALLED OUT ON
THAT, AND SHE'S RESPONSIVE AND
AS POSSIBLE FOR
THE CHRISTCHURCH SHOOTING?
THAT'S HOW PEOPLE FEEL AND
THAT'S THE TRUTH AND THEY ARE
TOLD THEY ARE RIGHT, THEY ARE
SPECIAL, THEY ARE WONDERFUL
INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE THEY GO TO
PLACES LIKE NYU AND THEIR
PARENTS TOLD THEM THEY WERE
SPECIAL.
SO OBJECTIVE FACT NEVER ACTUALLY
HAS TO BE BROUGHT INTO THE
CONVERSATION.
>> Laura: SPEAKING ON THE
RIGHT SET OF OF HISTORY, YOUR
BOOK, WE HAVE MAJOR HEADS
OF MAJOR DEPARTMENTS AT
PRINCETON UNIVERSITY, HE'S ON
MSNBC GETTING BACK TO THE
CLARY
DELMA CHRISTCHURCH SLAUGHTER.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID.
>> PART OF WHAT NEW CEILING
REPRESENTS IN AN INTERESTING WAY
MY VIEW A WHOLESALE ATTACK
ON WHAT DONALD TRUMP HAS
ENABLED.
I'M NOT TRYING TO BLAME WHAT
HAPPENED ON PRESIDENT TRUMP, BUT
HE'S HELPED CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT FOR THIS SORT OF
CARNAGE TO HAPPEN.
>> Laura: THAT'S WHERE IT'S
GOING FOR IT HE MIGHT NOT HAVE
PULLED THE TRIGGER, BUT IT'S THE
ENVIRONMENT OF TRUMP THAT
CREATED THE HATE AND THE
INTOLERANCE, ET CETERA,
ET CETERA.
THAT HAS REVERBERATED ACROSS THE
AIRWAVES, BEN, FOR THE LAST 72
HOURS PLUS AND IT'S STILL GOING.
>> THERE IS CERTAINLY A
NARRATIVE THAT'S BEING DRIVEN BY
THE LEFT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
CHRISTCHURCH SHOOTING.
EVERYTHING A PERSON IN WESTERN
CIVILIZATION WHO SAW THAT AND A
DECENT PERSON, APPALLED BY THAT
SLAUGHTER, OBVIOUSLY, AND THE
ATTEMPTS TO IMMEDIATELY JUMP
INTO THE MANIFESTO OF THE
KILLER, TO GIVE IT THE BROADEST
POSSIBLE COVERAGE BY THE MEDIA,
TO DO EXACTLY WHAT THE KILLER
WANTED, WHICH IS GENERATE ALL
SORTS OF POLITICAL CONTROVERSY
IN AN ATTEMPT TO TEAR APART
WESTERN CIVILIZATION, IS REALLY
QUITE DESPICABLE.
ONE OF THE THINGS I THOUGHT WAS
SO FASCINATING, IF YOU ACTUALLY
TAKE A LOOK AT THE MANIFESTO, I
RECOMMEND EVERYONE SHOULD NOT,
BUT IF YOU TAKE A LOOK, THE
KILLER SAYS ESSENTIALLY THAT
WESTERN CIVILIZATION IS WHITE
PEOPLE, AND WHAT YOU SEE FROM
THE INTERSECTION OF THE LEFT IS
A SIMILAR PERCEPTION OF WHAT
WESTERN ASSIMILATION IS BUT IT'S
A HIERARCHAL SYSTEM OF RACIAL
DOMINATION.
PEER THAT'S NOT THE WEST IS AT
ALL.
THAT'S WHY WE ALL MOURN THE
SLAUGHTER OF INNOCENT PEOPLE, NO
MATTER WHAT THE RELIGION LIVING
IN OUR CIVILIZATION.
>> Laura: THE RIGHT VIEW OF
HISTORY MEANS THE CORRECT VIEW
OF HISTORY WITH ITS THOUGHTS,
ACHIEVEMENTS, TRIUMPHS, SADNESS.
FINALLY, BEN, ON FOLKS THINKING
OF INVITING A CONSERVATIVE TO A
CAMPUS TO SPEAK OR A
CONSERVATIVE GOING THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO SAY, YOU KNOW, I'M
NOT DOING IT.
JERRY SEINFELD WANT TO PERFORM
IN COLLEGE CAMPUSES BECAUSE OF
THE POLITICAL CORRECTNESS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THOSE PEOPLE
WHO DON'T WANT TO DEAL WITH THE
GRIEF THAT YOU DEAL WITH?
>> I CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND IT,
BUT AT THE SAME TIME DON'T GIVE
UP THE FIGHT BECAUSE THERE ARE A
LOT OF PEOPLE HUNGERING FOR A
MESSAGE THAT IS TOLERANT NOT
ONLY OF HUMOR BUT ALSO TOLERANT
OF DIVERSE VIEWPOINTS FOR PEOPLE
WANT DISCUSSION ON CAMPUS.
I SPOKE AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
MICHIGAN LAST WEEK.
WE HAD A THOUSAND PEOPLE IN THE
AUDIENCE AND 6,000 PEOPLE ON THE
WAIT-LIST.
THAT'S NOT BECAUSE I'M SUMMING
SPECIAL BUT THERE IS A HUNGER OF
A DIFFERENT POINT OF VIEW FROM A
LOT OF THESE CAMPUSES BEING
SHIELDED BY THE ADMINISTRATION.
>> Laura: ON ACTUAL EXCHANGE
OF IDEAS.
WHAT A SHOCK.